Wackelpudding mit Waldmeistergeschmack -
mit der Natur hat das nichts mehr zu tun.
Denn der Geschmack der Kindheit kommt
aus dem Reagenzglas.
"Was mich jetzt mal interessieren würde:
Wie Waldmeister pur schmeckt."
Sebastian Lege zeigt uns, wie die
Industrie mit künstlichen Aromen unseren
Geschmack formt und dabei
eine Menge Geld spart.
Seit über 200 Jahren schwabbelt und
wackelt es auf unseren Tischen.
Ob Himbeere, Zitrone oder Waldmeister -
die Grundrezeptur von Wackelpudding hat
sich in dieser Zeit nicht groß verändert.
SEBASTIAN: "Um diesen Klassiker der Lebensmittelindustrie herzustellen, braucht man nur wenige Zutaten."
"Ein bisschen Gelantine, ein bisschen Zucker..."
Aus dieser Grundmasse könnte Sebastian jetzt unendlich viele Sorten herstellen.
Am liebsten macht er aber natürlich Waldmeister.
SEBASTIAN: "Das passt!"
"Das ist die klassische Wackelpudding-Waldmeisterfarbe."
Und der Geschmack liegt Sebastian auch schon auf der Zunge.
"Ein paar Tropfen Aroma und
zack! Wir denken, wir liegen im Wald in
einem Feld vor lauter Waldmeister."
Natürlich ist an diesem Geschmack aber nichts mehr.
Lebensmitteltechniker haben der
Natur ein Schnippchen geschlagen
und den Stoff Cumarin aus dem Wald-
meister im Labor identisch nachgebaut
Herausgekommen ist 6-Methyl-Cumarin.
Aber Waldmeister-Wackelpudding ohne
Waldmeister darf die Industrie das verkaufen?
Nein! Denn Waldmeister-Wackelpudding
müsste echten Waldmeister enthalten.
Die Industrie nennt das Produkt
daher Typ Waldmeister.
So darf es verkauft werden.
Übrigens: Auf der Verpackung wird das
Wort "Typ" oft sehr klein geschrieben.
Das Gesetz schreibt den Herstellern nur
vor, dass das Wort lesbar sein muss
Heißt für uns: Augen
auf bei der Typ-Suche!
Was schmeckt uns besser: Natur oder
Labor? Sebastian macht den Test!
Neben Waldmeister lässt er zur
Verkostung Himbeer und Zitrone antreten.
SEBASTIAN: "Mal sehen, was
den Leuten besser schmeckt!"
"Typ oder Natur?"
Wir beginnen mit Zitrone und Himbeere!
TESTERIN: "Also ich finde den gut."
"Schmeckt nach Kindheit."
TESTER: "Mmmh, der geht mal schnell ins Minus..."
TESTERIN 1: "Der schmeckt
ganz schön künstlich zitronig."
TESTERIN 2: "Aber ich finde ihn gut.
TESTER: "Woah, sauer!"
TESTERIN: "Den finde ich geil!"
"Der ist wirklich richtig zitronig!"
Bei Zitrone und Himbeere
gibt es keinen klaren Sieger.
Natürlicher und künstlicher
Geschmack liegen gleich auf.
Wie sieht es beim Waldmeister aus?
"Ihh!" - "Oha, wie eklig!"
TESTERIN" Kann ich nicht definieren."
Ein klares Ergebnis: Der natürliche Waldmeistergeschmack geht
mit null Punkten komplett unter.
Unsere Testesser entscheiden sich
einstimmig für das künstliche Produkt.
Für Sebastian ist das Ergebnis
nicht überraschend.
SEBASTIAN: "Die Leute kennen Waldmeister
wirklich nur durch diesen Pudding."
TESTERIN: "Was mich jetzt mal interessieren
würde: Wie Waldmeister pur schmeckt."
"Ich bin ehrlich, ich habe ihn so noch nie gegessen."
SEBASTIAN: "Bitteschön!"
SEBASTIAN: "Das schmeckt ganz lecker.
Kann man zu Hause auch in Limonade verwenden."
TESTERIN: "Ist aber nicht so intensiv. Hat nichts
mehr mit dem Waldmeister-Pudding zu tun."
Himbeere und Zitrone kennen wir
auch in ihrer natürlichen Form.
Bei Waldmeister hat sich dagegen
der Kunstgeschmack durchgesetzt
und unsere Vorstellungen klar verändert.
Für die Industrie sind künstliche Aromen
goldwert. Sie sind einfach zu verarbeiten
und deutlich günstiger als die
Naturprodukte.
Da überrascht es kaum, dass die
Hersteller auch bei Kaffee, Tee, Joghurt
und Kuchen auf die künstlichen
Geschmäcker zurückgreifen.
Wie beim Wackelpudding erkennt ihr das
durch das Wort Typ auf der Verpackung.
SEBASTIAN: "Typ ist nichts schlechtes,
aber auch nichts echtes."
"Wenn Sie genau wissen wollen, was drin ist,
dann schauen sie hinten auf die
Zutatenliste und vergleichen es mal mit
den Grafiken auf der Verpackung."
Ihr wollt keine Tricks, Checks und
Duelle der ZDFbesseresser verpassen,
dann aktiviert die Glocke neben
eurem Abonnieren-Button.